our series our more perfect union aims
to show that what unites us as Americans
certainly far greater than what divides
us
my aunt really used to always say that
President trumpet sharply reduced the
number of refugees who can legally enter
the United States next year the cap will
be 18,000 that's the lowest since
Congress established the refugee
resettlement program back in 1980 for
comparison the u.s. resettled nearly
85,000 refugees back in 2016 so major
Garrett traveled to one state where
Republicans and Democrats are putting
out the welcome mat major a good morning
to you good morning Gail heavily
Republican Utah has watched this decline
in refugee resettlements with alarm and
it has a message for President Trump
send us more not fewer refugees so my
mom was pregnant with me my twin sister
Osman de hare was born in Utah after her
mother fled a Kenyan refugee camp with
her three kids in 1998 a raging Civil
War had forced them from their home in
Somalia I would say Utah is the best
thing that happened to our family
because since we resettled here we had
countless of opportunities Utah is a
largely conservative state but it is
also one of the most refugee friendly
until president Trump's election it
welcomed upwards of 1,500 refugees per
year those numbers are down by
two-thirds now I have reduced refugee
resettlement by 85% Jacqui Pascucci the
Democratic mayor of Salt Lake and
Michelle khufu see the conservative
mayor of Provo disagree on some issues
but not this one
the refugee piece is really tender and
personal to us and it's a issue of the
heart for us in Provo City we are very
red state but we all agree that Utah
should be a welcoming state for Refugees
issues like this are bigger than our
partisans and our party's in October
President Trump boasted about new
executive action no refugees will be
resettled in any city or any state
without the express written consent of
that city or that state weeks later
Utah's Republican governor sent
his reply in this letter I encourage you
to allow us to accept more international
refugees in Utah I can tell you here in
Utah this has never been a partisan
issue our state was settled by
individuals that were fleeing religious
persecution
Utah's Republican House Speaker Brad
Wilson who supports president Trump and
like the governor is Mormon said the
history of the Church of Jesus Christ of
latter-day saints sustains the state's
commitment to refugee resettlement I
think it's just kind of in our DNA as
Utah ever felt overrun by refugees not
that I'm aware of
hey Marge a new Manya arrived in Utah in
2008 she fled violence in Burma for
Thailand when she was 13 how did you get
from Burma to Thailand 19 day I have to
get Thailand we walking walking yes she
became a US citizen in 2013 and helped
by a program for immigrant and refugee
entrepreneurs now owns their own Burmese
Thai restaurant we're not trying to
bring refugees here to take on our
low-wage paying jobs either we are
putting them on career paths they are
some of the most hardworking dedicated
people you'll ever meet and that's what
I would hope that President Trump would
see the mayor's also hope president
Trump would see what Ozma the hare is
doing now she's a public health major at
Westminster College in Salt Lake City
and plans to become a physician
assistant and she volunteers with newly
arrived refugees hoping to pay forward
the opportunities she's had it's a cycle
where younger folks who raise in Utah
have the ability to become successful
and then they want to reciprocate that
with future generations states and
cities have until Christmas day to tell
the federal government whether they plan
to continue welcoming refugees
Anthony major thank you so great to see
the cooperation there on that issue
Utah's an amazing state yeah
you